toutes les infections viennent de
l'environnement vient du sol viennent du
système racinaire des plantes ou tout
absolument des scientifiques de partout
sur la planète affirme que la relation
entre l'humain et son environnement
c'est en partie responsables de la
propagation de certaines maladies comme
la coved 19 en explorant la question
avec les cours qui déniait le gist jean
françois guigues à la recherche
excessive de nouvelles terres pour
planter du palmier à huile par exemple
et faut rester là amazonie brésilienne
pour le développement la production de
souches pas le même homme est en contact
avec des micro organismes naturels
qu'abrite sephora et donc dès lors il
est exposé à des nouveaux germes
deviennent les maladies vorbis dernières
années on a construit et des mégalopoles
bertrand dicale j'avais aujourd'hui 20
de plus de 8 millions d'habitants qu'il
faut bien nourrir ses populations et
donc dans les zones périurbaines on a
développé l'agriculture et l'élevage de
porcs de poulets mais aussi de canards
par exemple et ses zones péri urbaines
font la jonction entre la cité où vivent
les populations humaines et la diversité
biologique abritée par les forêts
tropicales donc s'engendrer la des ponts
entre l'un et l'autre et donc vous
favorisez les passages de micro
organismes à travers les systèmes
d'élevage vers les populations humaines
[Musique]
on va accuser les chauves-souris d'être
porteurs de ce virus voir des pangolins
pour le coronavirus mais je pense que le
problème en amont et bien l'impact que
les sociétés humaines exerce son
écosystème nature à partir de là qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire il faut avoir un
grand respect de ses pairs des sans
terre de diversité biologique de l'école
et consorts et apprendre à les respecter
bien vivre à dire avec autant de temps
que l'on ne cherche pas à exploiter ces
terres défrichées déforester
l'écosystème naturel
il est à risque de rencontrer de
nouveaux agents infectieux et certains
étant très mortelle pour l'espèce
humaine
donc ça demande une réorganisation
extrêmement important de la manière
d'autres voies concernées les villes
aujourd'hui dans le monde